hello did you hear all those mechanical
changes that Rob was making to his hot
arwing yeah yeah yeah I know right
what's up guys welcome to GameSpot live
we're live Monday to Friday today we get
to show you guys a new game called
StarLink here's one of the action see
the toys battle for Atlas exactly I like
that you should they should use that
voiceover we need you starfox exactly I
said only on the switch though yeah
here's one of them it's a toy so life
thing you have yeah the sweet do you
want to save that for later show now we
might not go full camera for a bit such
so freaking dumb yeah so also if they're
not realistic we'll get into it later
anyways here's an arwing anyways let's
get into the game we're gonna kind of
like explore kind of the open world you
guys were telling me it's kind of like
starfox in an open world at least again
on the switch this game is hard not to
point at two things okay on the switch
Gesell's okay settle it this game is out
on ps4 Xbox and switch ON switch
you only get starfox as in you it's
exclusive yep starfox and the missions
he gets where he goes against Wolff the
side missions that's only for switch
okay which makes sense because it is a
Nintendo property so there it is it's a
good hook let's just add like we'll be
real good hook because I will say that
this game is I and I heard the
comparison last week - no man sky and it
is it's like a no man skylight with Star
Fox in it point being this is the
biggest thing so you land on planets
you're in basically one system so
they're able to like get away with not
procedure
generation but like a manageable set of
locations right okay
so here's one planet it's just so man no
man's sky so you can switch into a mode
cook the gameplay a little bit so you
can switch into a hovercraft monster and
you can scan mommy's known just wow it's
just like no man sky your amazing guy
and it react and it's fun so I scan cool
yeah so I scan three of these complete
you got a partial scan so I gotta get
maybe we can find more of these mammoth
like a tree or a little too much oh
that's good that's good he's friendly
huh so it seems he or she most of Amar
yeah hello uh Jose from Argentina thank
you hi her birth hello sandy hello
Michelle and hello or do a barrel rolls
as Anthony tomatoes there you go hey how
long till you get that super sick thing
that you're showcasing it's on the
bottom left we'll get to it yeah we
gotta wait guys we got a rule that you
can do once that bottom left is it the
circle with the Arwen yes
so each so I can give another rundown on
stuff so one of the selling points this
game let me show you the one no man sky
other thing that is game so at any point
I can switch from hovercraft to flight
mode which is pretty fun and to like
switch back and forth well you can you
get out of your ship no okay so none of
that none of the act like that's all oh
yeah oh yeah
that looks familiar no man's guy and I
can warp to any planet how many planets
are there so it's like that's what
saying so it's like a it's like a
simplistic version of no man's sky so
okay it seems to be just one system
within that system or probably like your
typical starfox amount which is like
five six planets okay that's not bad is
more but they're all pretty big nice
hello flow from the Netherlands how you
doing
crime wants to know can you name
creatures name one but stall
no okay unfortunately we cannot can uh
what's up catastrophic welcome back
so the ship designs I like I think they
all feel and sound pretty cool so the
main selling point of this game right
and this is where the toys come in so
yeah this is not it's it's definitely
catered to kids for the toys yeah of
course so you you know you put your joy
Khan's in there while you're doing that
I'm not gonna do it okay I just want to
show it yeah so yeah we try lighter so
if you with the the unrealistic part is
that you have to have all these if you
have all these weapons and parts near
you so using wheat swap them I don't
know yeah you can kind of see top of the
the wings basically when it comes down
to it it it takes a while to find the
right part you might as well go into the
menu and just do it in game right it's
just way easier so at any point I can
swap with like you know there's
elemental types so you have like your
kinetic which is just guns blazing yeah
they're calling it vortex which is like
void
okay I don't know how's the class right
and this is just like a weird stasis
thing that'll knock people back and make
them fall and then you have your classic
like Frost's or overheating frost so you
you want a combo then on certain enemy
types that you certain you soon learn so
like a good one I like is like this
frost barrage and then this volcano okay
and it's tight though all the weapons
sound pretty cool okay
like I kind of like this game I'll be
yeah I always I saw you have it up on
the screen earlier today I add
originally asked Matt because I need he
was playing I didn't even realize you
were playing it and you're like I'm
actually haven't quite a bit of fun I
was like you know what you free at
eleven cuz you're even sort of startling
so you have like hazardous storms
that'll prevent me from flying and you
can see here in a second it's gonna kill
my flight capabilities and make me turn
into a hovercraft it's just fine okay
so you go around in this area zero sis
says that's not the arwing also when is
the review up I think the review I think
hopefully today I think it was in QA but
don't quote me on that can you use the
pro controller he's actually using the
pro controller a keel says can you crash
it yeah you can kind of crash which is
funny so like when you're on the ground
like this you kind of do some cool moves
you got like a jet boost get hot air but
you can also do kind of flips like this
so if you do them poorly for trying to
get stylish you can screw things up
should I do it gotcha
getting it tomorrow says Benjamin I love
cloud and will Donald they were my
favorite starfox characters that was AJ
Mason
Marc priest wants to know why is this
game 80 bucks on the eShop 75 for
physica physical probably is what do you
meant to say it comes with um there's so
many different iterations that you can
buy of this I believe yeah well makes
sense cuz there's the starfox one is
like a $75 bundle and it comes with this
arwing and a few of the little action
figures I think there's some other so
here's the are wings like aren't there
other like toy exclusives as well yeah
you also as wind zero says you don't
need the toys if you buy it digitally
you know it's correct so you get into
these menus and you can kind of get
creative and make you know ideal ideally
you're making cool-looking things so
like you can add you can stack wings
from other different jets more or less
so I could take like for instance
starfox wings here
oops from the arwing I could even like
flip them upside down just kind of neat
and then I can add another layer I
believe you can do another layer after
that it gets real crazy look at this
look how backi that is isn't that just
fantastic fantastic no more in sky and
almost can't 2.0 I'm not sure if you
have the answer for this one Rob I
definitely don't came the one but we can
try to figure it out
basically he's he or she's asking like
quiet he hate games right is it true
that the pre-order bonus ships and guns
are fully locked behind paywall
microtransactions and cannot be earned
in the game at all
you know ship parts no so he they're
asking is the pre owner pre-order bonus
ships and guns are those fully locked
behind microtransactions and paywalls
and cannot be earned in game do you know
if you don't know it's okay I don't know
which weapons that would be but I've
gotta say no no as in you have to pay
for it no Aizen I don't think that's the
case I don't think so I have to see the
toy I don't know okay I don't know
that's a good question we have a more
specific ship or weapons cane see what
was the question you just said you want
me to read again sure okay is it true
that pre-order bonus I thought you said
another ships and guns are those fully
locked behind microtransactions in
paywall and cannot be earned a game we
would need to pull up the pre-order
against in order to run that out because
I'm not able to distinguish what they
are I thought the pre-order bonus was
only a pilot says Jeremy I think there's
so many different versions these are
good questions hopefully we can answers
later d-link it says can use our win
without the toy being connected yeah yes
it's all the other ones you have well
yours you have the digital version right
yes yes that's correct so here's the
arwing so you know you also have mod so
you put on these that you get from like
scavenging and like yes mining and stuff
we're on this which no no
so like I have that one equipped these
are stats as you can see so BAM crime
says you can unlock ships and guns from
the Ultimate Edition pre-order in you
play using their points okay that's cool
okay so let's why don't we do a mission
these toys ships weapons definitely have
to be purchased digitally though
unfortunately because it's taking the
toy so life thing and putting them
digital however they are cheaper
digitally is what Jeremy says yeah there
are exclusive ships to Target and Game
Stop I know that but they are reskin of
the hawk and another ship gotcha
the hawk ship would that be okay so I
what the hell is this and widest box
look like that this is StarLink battle
for Atlas it's a game that's out for ps4
Xbox one and the Nintendo switch however
on the Nintendo switch as mentioned
earlier as an exclusive you play as fox
mccloud and the gang is his good bug
buddies pepe falco and i always forget
the other teammates I'm a terrible
person
Falco no I said Falco and Pepe what's
the slippy slippy the Frog there you go
you don't get to play as them
unfortunately but they can't they are in
the game d-link
that I'm not sure of we unfortunately
don't do the new stuff so although I
also wasn't there when they opened the
box for this were you there when they
open the box oh not really
d-link was asking about why the why
physical copies weren't sent but I'm not
100% sure so unfortunately I can't
answer that sorry
pokey master says I hate that I have to
wait 10 more hours for this game yeah
don't worry soon soon thanks for your
coming by and watching
so you find refineries across each world
you help them out and then you're able
to like bring back or and valuable
things that you mine and items within
the world and then you can flip that and
then you get mods for other things which
I could show like not you get more mod
slots you get more abilities for your
special equinox is your main it's like
the big home flagship as it says
StarLink it's like where everyone goes
and hangs out move we're gonna bet you
this is where like you have like you're
more like massive upgrades not like your
your niche upgrades for your weapons and
ship this is where you get like extra
mod slots for weapons and like your
special abilities you didn't top rights
better for the picture-in-picture just
in general probably huh I would say I'd
say I'd say side left I wish I had left
the only reason why I bought them right
then right left down above oh right left
yeah I think these are ways right left
to not make you know I got no I got I
got everything it kind of doesn't matter
because no matter what the menus at some
point we're just gonna show up I'll just
get rid of us when that happens is this
no foxes sky perhaps yes that's that's
right that's what it is all right so you
got a little side mission now oh wait
why not doing it
no don't okay and I was confused by this
okay so I miss what he was saying but
I'm doing a little side mission for him
thinking maybe I'm just killing these
guys nice wing zero asking how's the
performance on the swing uh it's pretty
solid it's pretty solid
like it looks definitely better on
docked and does handheld I prefer docked
cuz the controller yeah anything with
the controller is better than the joy
cons because I don't kind of hard to
control a ship like that mm-hm and you
melted those guys so yeah I'm gonna go
back to this combo cuz I like it so you
freeze them and then you heat them
alright I like it
almost like shake and bake yes yes but
not I'll think of a bad pun oh thanks
starfox he does kind of trip me out a
little bit there though in the bottom
left I love the way you look it's like I
guarantee it it's like ah [ __ ] oh oh he
doesn't he doesn't like you barrel
rolling into the ground man come on
streams where the were those people like
they can you know become an animal or
something
and every time they they talk or
something it kind of matches lip sync
you know and that's what he looks like
to me right now like a green screen guy
that's like streaming to you guys and I
mean it's it's freaky it's I would not
want that creeping into my dreams at
night pooty muffin basic or pouty sorry
pouty pouty morphing only reason to buy
this game is on the switch whoo and want
to play with that the starfox crew uh
it's hard to say you never know I would
have a hard time playing it
oh yeah starfox I get it but you have a
nostalgia right with starfox so I think
that it's hard to say but you know with
all the toys and action figures and
stuff like that you know like it could
be a way for ps4 and Xbox one etc to
have a chance
with the younger demographic a it's in a
way kind of cool because like I don't
know it's it's weird to think that in
the in the era that we live in now how I
see a lot of kids not actually playing
with action figures and things like that
as much as you know back when I was
younger because they all have like iPads
or like you know their parents cell
phone or something like that right
whether they have screen time as my
fiance would say as a teacher that maybe
it's good to have some of these toys to
life kind of things so then like you
know like you got this cool arwing you
know he probably like your son or your
daughter could take this out when you're
like going out to the well actually I
guess you'd have the switch with you
know I wouldn't let my kid walk around
with it you just feel like hey you know
what we can't play anymore but you can
take you know you can bring your arwing
with you you know to the to dinner or
something you know Sammy
you're done you're done for the day take
a toy I won't take the toy go bring it
outside to get it get it get it dirty
outside yeah yeah exactly
I hear you that's some good parenting
right there parenting and that's that's
good
so I won't have to severely try to limit
my child's screen time you know it's
funny when you think about like if and
when you're gonna have a child like
you're like oh yeah I'm never gonna give
them the iPad like I'm never gonna give
it to them and then you realize probably
how difficult it is to raise a child and
how much of a break you need that like
you can just give them the iPad for like
an hour to and you're like thank God I
have a break for sure man our back to
the chat sorry guys I kind of went on a
tant off on a tangent there so I feel
like every time I do on these outposts
yeah silence tag no on foot all all ship
all the time
let's go god you're slow dude this is
just like a traditional MMO you got to
follow the ping hell is slow and then
you gotta you know protect them maybe oh
I can do the cool thing d-link one zero
one three says in all honesty do you
guys think this game including the ship
is worth the price I think the toys are
dumb if you're someone my age and
personal that's your personal opinion
yes you should not yeah I don't know but
you were not we're not gonna realize
it's it's way quicker to be like all
right I'm gonna go with this weapon then
have to find it on your couch and pick
it up I got you but again we we know
that the toys part of it is probably
catered more to of course to the
children and or people that are huge
fans and just want to play around with
it you know right these guys yeah a
little beetle beetle but I think that
you're enjoying the fact that at least
on switch you have Star Fox Star Fox
play it but it feels good the gun the
game feels good to fly and to shoot and
all that stuff oh crap so it's not good
good yeah it sounds good with a little
some good mechanics yeah yeah it's cool
but Star Fox
because the story in this game is is
also very bare and like and it reminds
me very much of a kids game everyone's
like exaggerating when they talk which
works for starfox like when you have
Starbucks throwing the Knicks it's like
alright cool cuz Starbucks is you know
all the story within those games is
equal it's just like very cliche and
corny and it's like I'd rather have a
talking Fox do that then like someone
someone denied someone I don't know you
know and again it's like it I'm able to
like it and digest it easier is a toy
airplane you can technically write you
said it's a thing I said you could
technically play with this with oh yeah
yeah okay hold on let me you're just
flying around right now right yeah I'm
gonna go full camera so I don't know if
you guys can see this but this is
essentially like the controller where
you would put the two joi cons on now I
don't know how how how that feels you
know cuz you'd be playing like this and
then you'd have to you know then switch
weapons if you wanted to right like that
I'm gonna go back to the game now as you
can see whatever actually you know what
it actually doesn't feel that bad it is
just a little weird in my hand just not
being used to something like you know
protruding but it's not like overly
heavy where I feel like I wouldn't be
able to play it's cool toy man it's cool
toy oh yeah could you imagine how hard
it would have been if they had to do
like characters running and also Fox
army around yeah alright so you want to
see the cool thing about spot Fox's
special ability can you play this in
mobile mode or does it have to be docked
in some way no you could play it
handheld but like you said it looks
better Doctore yes yeah like most the
toy is to do barrel rolls
oh oh it's why I turned my controller
upside down to do it in order to do it
dude how much swag would it be for you
to like spin it catch it and be like
yeah look at the head
probably unrealistic what do you
possibly Equinox foxier when the main
thing I want more people to cover as the
strategy elements I heard there was base
building an outpost building and such I
don't know anything about base building
okay I mean I just there you saw me like
helping out a refinery which is gonna
help me like it's more or less a base
that I bring Nova or and stuff to in
order to like again like mod out your
ship my ship and like my stats for
character and stuff so here I'm gonna go
off planet and do this kind of side
quest thing we'll do a barrel roll with
the toy later okay well well I'll I'll
subject rob to have to play that way for
like the last 30 minutes is that too
much is thirty minutes too long it
sounds a real bit 15 minutes 15 you got
to do 15 alright he's gonna have to do
15 I'm changing gear I'm doing can you
play with joy Kahn's in both hands I
don't see why not
or do you have to have a dog alright
like for joy Kahn's to have them both
one you just have can you just play with
you icon yeah okay the game comes out
tomorrow right I believe so yes that one
and just missed this dude the what Kay
there's one thing that's really
frustrating with this game is that every
time I'm trying to do a quest it'll like
Auto switch me to main campaign like I
don't it's very frustrating
we're not a lot of show Kevin right
thing is a belief they just said don't
show any huge story spoilers whatever
that means and then you have a cool side
mission that we also are told kind of
not to spoil either so he was like my
secondary speed where I can go like
faster in space oh I think I bleach was
the one that said that it's unfortunate
that you can't there's no multiplayer so
there's a little hole in that I was able
to like fly through and continue on my
warp but now I pulled out well that's
cool you want to see this you want to
see the special Oh are we doing it here
yeah we're doing it all right hold on
I'll go full audio for you then alright
that bottom-left special that we hyped
up 20 minutes ago he's about to use it
so I think it's cool is it every hour
you said or is it now that was exact
I was exaggerating it's like every leg
maybe five minutes or so oh okay are you
ready for it
these guys want my special let's do it
get your photo
just for this sound this music alone
oh yeah
this ain't looking good for you what
you're the one killing their ships how
could
yeah it sucks like you can only engage
this I know I'd have it on repeat sup
Fox night what killed everybody I want
more of that I'm just that good when I
call one of my calling them up one of my
boys know you calling you one of your
boys - right that's what away one of the
dude I know it gets me riled up man that
songs good and now it's just empty space
and I want to play this game anymore
that's another good question dealing
I'll have to find out for you the
question is do you need to swap the
weapon the physical weapons in order to
swap in-game weapons with the physical
coffee what yeah that would be weird if
that was the case I would assume that
you'd have to be able to do it both ways
but I can definitely ask you do not you
know things up like if you had the
physical copy no that wouldn't guess I
mean you never know there was a another
question oh [ __ ] there's another
question and I don't know I don't think
you've beaten it yet though right right
no I'm ok so someone was asking like is
it endless content after you beat it so
what are those one of those refineries I
like helped out Matt was I haven't had
this happen to me and it may have
happened to early on in our play just
now I I miss it those refineries can can
become under attack and you have to go
like help him out so there's a lot of
like reasoning to come back to certain
elements of this game I would say which
you could argue is like the endgame
even that like your exploring planets a
lot of times too so like I can zoom in
can i okay so there's two ways to play
the game corn and Jeremy physical toys
are digital is if you go physical you
have to use a toy on the mount to change
weapons etc sounds ridiculous for the
physical that's that's what Jeremy
Eldridge is saying for the physical
version I just tuned in can you get out
of the ship in this game no you can't
box night
that's ridiculous if you have you I find
that very hard to believe of physical
would wouldn't make you do that cuz that
that means that is making you use this
controller and you can't use pro
controller or the joy cot or I guess the
door grinds you can't use oh I think
that no no it's not that
it's that you can't I think what they're
trying to say is that you can't switch
the weapons in the game without actually
manually switching on the toy not that
you can't use the controllers and things
like that but like or I guess what
you're saying makes sense you know but
I'm saying is like they're what heat
what is being said in the chat is if
you're using the mounting the physical
version of this game you have to use
this okay so you said any not use a
program he said misquote if you're using
the mount which I would assume is this
yeah if you don't have the mount you
don't have to use the toys but if you're
using the the mount then you have to use
that then you okay there you go sorry
Thank You Jeremy for the information I
appreciate it there you go let's just go
straight to that there aren't many games
that come out for their heavy
merchandise I actually thought police to
life as a concept was dying out because
you know Disney infinity stop yeah I
think you mean Skylanders stop doing it
or is this kind under still exist I
don't think so right and the closest
things we have to that now is amiibos
but those aren't like yeah yeah I know
but they're not so integral to the
actual game
yeah cool oh smart that does sound
pretty good
also do ya only 69 hits you just hit
there that's my favorite gun so I can
show some otherwise yeah like this one's
pretty cool I can switch up the ship
we'll go with this one do you like that
family seating think Irrfan is saying
you don't have to you can just scan the
toy once and it'll let you use them
digitally so so physical version comes
with digital copies but you can swap out
digital parts on a physical part yeah is
it Oh
slappy noodles here your son hello son
how do you switch tips I did and I
switch weapons all right so let's do
what do we do mission we're doing a side
mission on gang site Raksha Finders
Keepers nice it's okay you wanted to
show off some that space combat you want
to show off that's six special dude do
you know what I'm imagining so that's
just Fox's special as it should be yes
yes I don't know what the other specials
are so we'll have to see what they are I
got changed the character then so you
don't need to bot so you don't need to
have the toys to life if you buy online
that's correct right have you just buy
digital you don't need the toys I mean
you've never used the toys I still feel
like we're getting caught up in the toys
no I know but someone's asking if you
only bought digital yes which you have
you have not used the toys once correct
I was never given it yeah exert exactly
there you got boom boom done you don't
need two toys it's really hot
holy holy this is the swellest it's all
this toy talk cuz toy talk making me hot
alright I'm gonna change this let's step
away from Fox for a little bit and this
Fox ever talk yes he does
dude he talks all the time it's a barrel
yet I did like barrels like non-stop
there you go thank you I'm sick now I'm
sick stop it okay stop it
see let's try metalhead damn they'll
have that sick cinematics
[Music]
yeah razor and then we got pilot skills
to worry about Eric yep
you got to have the skills to pay the
bills all right so she also seems to
have music special theme going on here I
just wanna play Dark Souls on mice which
says wolf that's soon right
we're actually I think allowed to show
some gameplay later this week not that
people haven't seen it before because
there was that network test but I think
that's on its way
19th for switch so yeah end of the week
at the Friday yeah yeah
when's the StarLink review GameSpot
asked juvenille ATAR today I know it's
in the QA process today but the latest
one oh yeah David Morgan does this game
have legendary finds like mods so you so
the lessons may be well you're not
really finding weapons again you're
gonna craft those you don't really get
any more weapons as far as I know no
really yeah these you start off with all
these weapons oh it's the mod it's the
mods you are getting see the exclamation
marks there this is what you're focused
this is the loot
so like blues or the highest I've seen
so far and how many hours in are you
roughly like five or six so yeah and
you're also getting like mods so like I
have obviously the arwing souped up yeah
I can't wait for a Diablo on switch
that's gonna be next month though 11 -
oh this is legendary so I got these
randomly I forgot how and those those
are the straight power-ups right there
yeah yeah even those on that's for sure
anyways oh yeah I didn't pick all right
linked to TV passes you don't need the
toys for both digital and physical
copies this isn't rocket science
hey man it ain't easy talking toys to
life so watch that good there so
sometimes the no man's sky of entering a
planet has that like kind of like pop
well it's not a pop in it's just clearly
to crossfades of two different like
there was one time where it was really
noticeable where it was like not as
seamless as like no man's sky has it now
pretty pretty sweet we're like you see
like a weird Canyon and chances are
you'll see when you reach down there
there's one time we're just clearly
cross fated into something completely
different but it's 84 you 80 euro oh you
swapped off starfox yeah so this is like
a side mission where so it's the story
should I explain the story I mean if you
want TLDR it TLDR there are these bad
guys okay so this guy named dr. Grande
or his name's Grand something anyways he
found this like robot he found this
robot named judge and is one of the only
people in like the whole universe now
who can like make nova which is I guess
like Nova's like a fundamental element
that helps like star travel and all that
stuff I'm pretty sure I'm nailing it
right anyways everyone in this crew
works for StarLink Fox just shows up
with his squad and I go there's some
crap going on cuz these guys star links
under attack
and then this bad the villain of the
whole thing I think he's under the
Legion which is the enemy race I think
he comes in and he steals dr. grant or
whatever and now they're all trying to
find him
and in fact the bad guys are saying that
basically he's got a gun against dr.
Grant's head he's like making some Nova
he's like I will never do that that's so
dark man yeah it's messed up dude
there's a space gun I guess what's crazy
is when you see like a kid that's
probably less than four years old
watching venom that happened last Friday
anyways that was my random fun fact for
the day have you tried any uh no okay
someone was asking about motion controls
we'll find out in a little bit when we I
would turn that off baby I don't my big
fan of motion controls hello Gopal how
are you so I need another is this a
battle royale game where a hero she oh
my god twice nice Richard maybe there
will be a deal for Black Friday
all right so we need to find another
call so yes thank you Jeremy for all the
insight we appreciate it
yeah you love it told you oh you don't
even have it anymore or does your
special carryover later it doesn't carry
over to a different character that's
unfortunate
so we got to wait like we got to wait
like another like 20 minutes probably to
like well now it's a different character
so I want to see what her special is but
we're definitely not going to be as good
as starfox that's for sure another
powerup link I don't know where to find
it is it that little conduit guy you
could go or you're learning the mission
yeah there's some weird stuff going on
right now
didn't it right oh do I just go back and
do this okay sorry I'm just trying to
figure out what I'm supposed to be doing
cuz it's not really telling me
okay oh you just swap it yeah but I
close the gate and turn yes yeah I did
so I should probably do it on the other
one then little puzzle a little bit how
is the plan of variety like yeah I
probably have that do at the plant a
variety I've only been to like a couple
planets there there it a little
different like you get like different
like biomes where I like a little desert
action there's one that's like straight
no man sky as far as like the color
palette it's like it just looks exactly
like oh man sky there's totally one in
there how do I get there oh I'll just
fly
and sitting do this
there she is
hooyah oh crap
way to grab it wrong button you just
wanted to fly wouldn't you want this car
this I want to say a car because it
sounds like a car is like a sports car
it's got cool engine noise Richard Lloyd
ask anyone have a good suggestion for
switch games I have Zelda just bought
for whenever talking first party only or
you doesn't matter
oh yeah oh yeah yeah well yeah I can
tell
so you have a shield too which is kind
of cool it burns energy like your
boosters or your your thrusters up or
your boosters forward look at you
waiting for regen like a smart person
sweet grand personal log subject judge
st. grant and I thought years ago and
think Parliament Arctic January's Brian
I think for stopping by
that electron and inside a truly alien
species thousands of individual
creatures existing as a single
collective and they were dying I built
them a protective suit and gave them a
name Judge Dredd the judge couldn't
remember anything about where we candies
outs which are great I agree
dead cells was a good one it's pretty
much become the ports and she knocks
program and began the search for judges
homeworld
as someone who started Valley addition I
made contact with a by on scientists in
debris into the bridge things like
perfect for the switch exactly or maybe
I just didn't want to she asked me to
help her finish her research I said no
dang young and naive I have to admit
that after meeting his brother cells is
great on all platforms I agree with
those weird for I am a bunch perhaps and
then I fell off a cliff I don't know why
I beat it on normal and I beat it on one
like one skull and then I didn't want to
do it on two scotch did you I met dr.
Thorne ages grades splatoon Mario are to
see if you haven't played that yeah
Mario ever light drifter how was that
for you though I thought you said there
was some that's some framedrops that's a
go on cuz I mean we're looking for a
full on oh yeah I'm sorry what do you
have show if all you have is Zelda on
you're looking for the next like fix
then you get Odyssey
okay so darkest dungeons should we do a
main campaign sure you think I don't
have a big story spoilers well why don't
we just continue actually on this side
one no I think about it
okay I'm juicing my mind progress mind
oh so I have to do that I have to do
main campaign so what I want to do it
I'll apologize later
yeah let's swish my [ __ ] why not did you
want to see this person's thing though
oh do you keep the pilot doesn't matter
yeah I'll just change the ship so I'll
just pick something cool like that looks
cool let's just do this ship here you
can't get starfox on ps4 words it's a
Nintendo switch exclusive Diablo try
says greetings from Croatia greetings
hello thanks for tuning in what
platforms will this game come out on its
on the switch ps4 and Xbox one
Oh Mario Party we had a fun time doing
that poor people in here me and Joey
were severely behind and of course in
great Mario Party fashion luck favored
us and we ended up winning but yeah
that's close one definitely close one
may pick up that cooking game force
which heard that was good overcooked yes
is the name it's a yeah if you have
friends play with I wouldn't I don't
know if I'd get that game if I didn't
have any friends oh I didn't notice any
framerate drops on our end Marcelo
but I don't know maybe I'm curious if
anyone else whoops in the chat has
experienced any of that or not and
you're still fine you know is the really
annoying part so you have your look
behind you right hi doing you yeah your
ability to look behind you
the problem is that so when I engage it
my flood my controls of flight as in
like lift change so for instance if I'm
if I'm like pulling up and I'm doing
this mmm it swaps it goes the other way
does that make any sense so I pull up so
I'm pulling up and now after now I net
now I nosedive when I look behind so it
like flips I don't know why it wouldn't
be consistently say I'm flying there's
someone behind me like let's go
what is like I'm stuck in an asteroid
forever stuck dude I am you gotta
recover out of that asteroid you
shouldn't have flipped into it no I'm
stuck in an - a warped into it that's
what you get
do it moderately awkward
so you think out of the warp you got
stuck in the asteroid to be yeah I can
look you can see it and it's totally
stuck inside of it find your way out
well then I'm guessing you can't blow up
asteroid either no I think I gotta
reload the game you you die and I could
do this I'm about to die actually yeah
that's fine what if I do this
fly right into it uh no because now I'm
in a fight so won't let me warp faster
I'm sure verse Rob Ashford wins are you
gonna do could you kill yourself just
now you think this is the end game no
this is not definitely not the end game
oh no our wings down Oh No okay there's
a different ship are you still stuck
are you I'm gonna beat the game again
all right you can't beat the game
against the game again all right you
know things happen things happen as
Jeremy said PSA you don't have to buy
the toys to play the game I know they'll
have to repeat that forever yeah it's
it's you are on point
see you can well you could have this
good which we're gonna play with in a
little bit Rob's gonna have himself a
great time taking you a barrel roll you
know what if I what if I just constantly
played that great song on my phone and
then you're just like dun duh-da no I'm
really trying to buy time right now guys
and I'm not even lying I'm trying to buy
time do the same thing warp out I think
you tried to warp out didn't you I was
unable to warp because I was in combat
yeah I got you cool toy it doesn't feel
too flimsy either actually hey tanner
Nintendo didn't make this game so got
him alright so let's take off where we
were hopefully I'm not inside this toy
is not terribly expensive I guess in a
way because I think you can buy the
starfox starter pack which comes with
the arwing and it's $75 so you're
essentially paying like $15 issues for
the arwing right in theory if the game
was $60 what happened at Thursday's
great poppers Rob we are gonna take a
break from grave robbers we'll take off
in November mid November just because
this month has been so crazy
oh so you saved where you were Yeah
right you didn't lose any another
extractor if you can destroy it
do you think that should work we hit a
bug just now guys if that's why we got
to help fern hello he doesn't fly RDR
week oh I mean I pass that along to rob
the weak it comes out that maybe we just
stream Red Dead every day what do you
think about that Rob's read that every
day for a week or just one - yeah
no it'll you'll get your Red Dead fix oh
these guys are
oh there's skulls to you that bad yeah
that's probably that's real bad I'm just
using my destiny logic here that they're
probably real strong you know what
they've done to is they'll hit like try
to engage and fly away and they keep
hitting me and preventing me from
getting over yeah like I got worse by
some of these guys once let me bring out
the big boys the big boys what's the big
boys I do want to see your special but
let's just get right into this if I can
take these guys out so you don't think
it's a stall this topography damn it
nailed it
okay they're not they're not their level
AIDS so at least you can do damage to
them oh yeah there you go work on the
shield yep three engage engage they're
fully restored shield oh there you go we
just need a box so they don't do the
whole flip huh
what do you mean like you know how like
old-school 64 they do the whole like
yeah all the way up and around it takes
a while right like here I think I think
they did it just right it's a nice coil
around lift barrel be right back in it
yeah yeah you can't hit me can't hit
this the Fox
how many planet um
he's only 5 to 6 hours in Geo but he
ventured to guess like somewhere like 5
to 6 take a little more I think was a
little more than that
let's see real quick those Vulcans the
sound of the weapon in July 4 5 6 in the
Sun maybe who knows but there's so
outside there's like a la hideouts and
stuff so there's a lot of stuff in space
that you can do too this was pretty cool
you like take down a ship yeah and then
you let go inside the [ __ ] up and do
stuff I gotta I gotta get rid of us
oh no they can see the ship that's fine
yeah there's stuff to do outside of
just the planets as well yeah but
weapons sound cool right like they all
have a lot of cool noises I can I can
show you like the Gauss Gauss recog Wow
go Gauss it just makes me think of doom
though
yeah it's similar oh the states this is
this the levitator yeah this one's good
too it'll like stun the enemies oh yeah
oh wow it shoots pretty much well you
got Scouts candy yeah it's got the sound
effects are dope like it's it's hard not
to like say this game doesn't sound and
feel poachers kill that guy see how you
got down yeah it's cool
yeah well convo while he's like stuck in
stasis stasis overload so I guess he's
on cooldown yeah okay we can oh okay
nice hi
so there's no fun combinations you could
play around that's alright
oh this is a cool one so get this vortex
one so I just found this out today I was
kind of using it wrong so you got the
imploder and then what you can do is the
employer does like a kind of like a like
a giant explosion and then you can throw
an atom elemental at it so it's
basically so the vortex will look tat so
say you're dealing with like a bunch of
ice guys like these guys I need to use
like overheating so I can use the
imploder and say this and like combo it
like in this respect to watch our fire
this guy purple and then I shoot it and
make it fire vortex Wow okay yeah so
that's good for like AoE having a leg a
lot of damage I didn't law smaller guys
Courtland Robinson asking is StarLink a
must buy for the switch
I think that's tough I think that this
version of the three though if I was
gonna buy StarLink is probably the one I
would buy and I think the same for you
but I have a nostalgia like I have a tie
with Star Fox yeah me too but but you
also said that yeah see he wasn't happy
about that you also said that there are
other elements to it like you know if
the stories it feels a little bit better
or maybe a little bit more I don't know
I don't know what the right word is here
but with Star Fox you felt like it was
more reasonable right then without them
yeah no yeah but like and it's not bad
like stand alone without Star Fox like
the stories are like passable like it's
it's nothing like gripping but it's also
not bad where I'm like cringing or
frustrated with it it's just enough for
it's like it it's it's enough to like
keep you going I'm somewhat interested
but again like the core combat and
flight yeah of this game is fun like
it's it's cool to like kill the engines
and just do this and just fly around
yeah we're on a foot and then like tape
back up off again like yeah it's like
it's a little bit more expensive outside
of the u.s. apparently for just a bunch
of interesting and old-school gamer says
the digital standard version in UK is 93
dollars just finally converted damn iso
i cuddle you really quick this is a
great calm right now right
not today suckas oh we're so close to
having ourselves a good time again I
mean we're having a good time but like
you know a real good time you know what
though I'm actually a little bit
surprised that chat didn't really pop
off more when that when we had her
special go off or some there was
definitely something oh sure I do it
again whoa oh I didn't mean to ya you
now we are
for one enemy yes oh no it hurts
get in there slippy all right at least
you can fly around
that's over now we wasted it I wasted it
sorry I'll get it I was trying to have
my shield which is that good do this
let's do this man came campaign can you
leave the atmosphere at any time like no
mascot yes you can like this yes you can
Nathan
and you even scan animals like well
there are seven that we can see right
now on the map so we can't do too much
story yeah they would prefer that we
don't do any big story spoilers so we're
probably get a little bit through this
one mission just to see where it takes
us to see if it opens anything up we're
also gonna probably we can't get out of
the ship Chris it's all ship all the
time
you can either hover mode or fly around
as Ravitch oh I'm gonna make Rob play
with this in a little bit it's gonna be
great look at some action down here get
it oh sweet there's like a nice StarLink
Ubisoft facts on the Ubisoft site I will
link that in the chat you guys need it
uh-oh is that like a different sauce or
something yeah he's got a emblem on his
name oh we got to avoid some stuff it
became a shmup oops that's all right
trying to try to look cool well that
thing is doing the damage combo oh great
dodge rub jello frost for text now
what's interesting is like they're
turning into frost not me
Oh like yeah so he'd they fired before I
could fire my oh so then my painting of
us yeah
you gotta take this thing out I think
that's his tower or an extractor oh did
you charge your vortex I charged the
imploder which does the vortex thing
things tanky am i doing any damage yeah
you are you're doing damage he's heading
a half Oh
so Nova is this thing that's like a rare
mineral I can also throw it at people
for elemental [ __ ] oh that's two ice
giants all right we got ourselves a
little well action
all right so they're probably weak to
fire right I would assume cannot get the
role right
oh so I'm also in a there was fun
talking if you guys are curious I was
also in a I'm also in this like crazy
storm so I can't fly Oh gotcha
that's just about ask you that you must
have read my mind
yeah that's a fire you tried this - all
right we're changing it's changed as
weapon here weapon do some oh this is
cool this is probably to be a suicide
but this is a cool one it's not what I
want to hear oh now what now I get the
hell out of here okay oh you frost no
but yourself or well you know but they
shot Frost and then yeah so is that most
like a like a battering ram yeah pretty
much which is going great with this
broadside I knock a little bit I asked
you else I got like a flamethrower
yeah and I'll use
whoo I like to see I like the volcano
the most yeah the wings are very much
close close range like you said I think
based off the combo yeah now you're fine
still I think I think okay I got a guy I
see I see now I see the way now I know
the way come on special we need you we
need Falco to come down here and lend
some support I believe Cortland he's
just in the starter edition of the
switch right if I have that clarity the
version I have what is included in the
digital StarLink Oh
starter pack oh all digital starter
packs retail for $59.99 is the digital
one pluses for starships the Nintendo
switch Digital starter pack also
includes fox mccloud exclusive star walk
fox mission and our win star chip oh
nice I didn't even get to see you
destroy that because I was reading the
FAQ I also posted that link in the chat
so you guys can check that out if you
need to it's a pretty good source
it's funny that they throw so it's like
they throw starfox into this in all it
feels if you play a starfox like it just
feels like starfox in a different game
yeah it's it sounds dumb to say but it's
really as I'm playing it's just like it
just feels like starfox name is Kukai
thrown into a completely different
universe
and it's kind of fun to play it as that
and imagine that it was it is in fact a
starfox game like it's it's interesting
keep on no you can you can just like
swap and be a different character and
then starfox won't even show up in the
chatter because the whole the whole team
that's what I'm trying to say like the
whole team will talk to each other no
matter what like I'll be you know this
guy Mason and he'll chime in but if I am
chase he'll still chime in with the same
dialogue but Starbucks won't ever chime
in as far as when I'm when I'm playing
only when starfox is like when he gets
to talk to all these other people so he
feels very out of place and I make sense
in the sense that it's exclusive right
to switch so he it's just funny to play
as starfox in this game TV Savage we're
playing a starling battle for Atlas but
on the Nintendo switch which then allows
you to play as starfox in the cloud
razor Danny was basically saying he
hopes that this doesn't Deacon firm a
new development for a development for a
new starfox game I mean like this is
completely separate from what Nintendo
themselves are doing so you know I don't
think that that's necessarily the case
so it's just any good or or not I mean
Rob was having fun with it but with the
preface that you know he's enjoying the
switch version because it does have
starfox it does have the arwing it does
have some of that nostalgia in it
yeah and they enjoyed regardless like to
play I play mechanics he likes the
flying he likes the shooting mechanics
he like switching the weapons and things
like that the combinations he can do
also you know you were a fan of nomads
guy it has like some Nomad skylight and
stuff going on yeah for sure alright so
I'm just gonna request a mission on this
planet uh was it actually confirmed
board 79 did you hear about that leaked
like 64 mini or 64 classic structures
holes whatever I think I saw that like
rumor or something on on reddit or
something I haven't seen the cosmos for
eyes I'm also behind today I've what's
up next I'm just gonna do this quick
side thing cool and then you're gonna
put my con in here right Paul Cook says
there are a total of seven planets in
the game that's what we counted but
again Rob's only five hours in if that's
a confirmed confirm on your part then
cool if not then you know that's all we
saw so far these guys doing standing
Frosty's what they're doing
oh hello he got punted up ball back in
oh wow I didn't know you could shoot two
of those oh do you have your thing
bottom left or is it grayed out
it's red meat oh I have it yeah
we gotta use as many times as possible
that's fair especially since you're
fighting some some bad dudes anyway this
BALCO never come he does he's come so
they all take turns I know but we've
seen peppy and slippy
get your butt in here Pepe
what what he didn't even help out why
does it always cancel I'm in a fight
Pepe
maybe because he you're too far from the
action we should switch up the character
for the sake of it
why though I know I want to see what
other characters of specials are because
I because they see about the locks
thousands of times this is their level 8
you are gonna get they're gonna be
skulls too you know and then but special
of these these other characters oh just
your our wing that's level I know what
I'm trying to say is the special I did
with Star Fox no what I'm saying is
you're gonna lower your level which
would then make those fights harder to
deal with right it's fine alright I'm
hella good this game silence hella good
I don't know I have nothing to compare
it to so well Joker I don't have any
frame drops on my streaming platform so
and I haven't seen any here on the
screen so maybe lower your resolution on
your stream perhaps see if that helps
you I haven't really seen any other
complaints other than maybe one person
but yeah
what do you do here find the right I've
had something before and I understand
unlock permanent anchor before I've done
this and it's just like oh you just use
different elements namely private right
Frost Thanks
got a frost planet so you're right Oh is
there a little puzzle aspect to the
puzzle oh oh that might be the middle
one because no oh look they all line up
yeah that was for the bottom smooth this
one that one's left right that one
that's over there well this one's here
yeah move that down yep yep you get in
there yeah oh no way that's fine still I
think cuz you can't move that one move
did I screw myself up now I gotta do
this watch isn't that top right one
annex so if you alright
I'll let you figure this out I think you
just screwed it up though I think you
were well I might be able to
course-correct from here
you know if it all the way around your
madman I like it though
now you got it yeah
her weight yeah I'm good yeah yeah you
good nice work Rob yes puzzles Karl that
new element no that's a cross was like
arc warden isn't that one it was
probably a weapon yeah I was it was a
weapon type it was this one that's a lot
of range hundred oh wait was that the
overall that might be that it's 15%
damages 6% kritis that's always good I
like it more damage does anyone actually
enjoy slide puzzles that seems like
they've just bum everyone out I think
they're fine as long as they don't take
me hella long to figure out but
sometimes I'm Tara block puzzles this
reminds me of throwing access to
complete puzzles and God of War a little
bit more complicated though I guess
they're right to do this story let's do
it I mean sure we have about 20 more
minutes in which case you're gonna have
to do this soon all right all the people
have to know people have to know here we
go guys we're gonna go we're gonna we're
gonna put the Troy Khan's in here and
Rob's gonna play with this controller
there you go if you guys can see it
slide the joy Khan's in there you would
swap the weapons you can swap the
weapons the focus is yeah I can't put it
too close the cameras
manual focused right now so thanks Rob
don't make that face people need to know
the people deserve this Rob boom clicks
and ooh oh we are ready so hard to put
your fingers around you're just used to
a pro controller all right yeah I'm used
to a controller that actually feels good
I feel like my fingers David Morgan feel
sorry for you as he should
Eric the mad scientist I'm not a mad
scientist you should just break the toy
definitely don't do that all right here
we go
I think you scanned it so it's oh dude
he's a stone Fox killer look at this
what's up
psych dude that was worth it oh I don't
care that was a hundred percent worth
100% worth Rob I don't care
oh so did it Otto picked Fox so maybe it
does work all right let's try this
so can you change the weapons then yes
we have other pauses that's do we do we
have no but you gotta have time to
switch
dude you how do you know how much an APM
you would have that up oh it does have
weapons or wila
am i good to open this yes you are
oh so if you put this ship on
hypothetically this would work to
correct hold on hold on hey Rob
would you like to break this okay Rob
would you like a void missile rocket
things yes please why don't you put it
on for me totally on my right wing
please yeah have another fire with
vortex missile Rockets now you're
speaking my language Erik is the outlaw
character
okay this is not meant for children open
apparently or maybe adults with big
hands really just
all right so this is oh dear take off oh
I lost away oh geez
oh you can straight up wing Oh hold on
straight up well no you want that you
want the picture so here's a piece and
we put it on and now we have that sick
now I have a weird there's a pretty
seamless though oh you don't have a
weapon on there hold on I wish you
didn't pause the game well what you
expect to be able to fly while you're
doing that you're gonna reverse put on a
wing dude my wings are dude like you
know I can't believe that actually works
and shoot the other way that dude that's
a meta like if someone's chasing you you
just flip the wing around that's it come
on you guys have to say that's actually
kind of cool
I think it's cool I think it's cool that
it that it works that it doesn't just
like air out on you and like not work
alright here we go let's go so you can
get in here box out of the picture I
know bursts are on the docks reverse our
wing here on Orthodox oh you're just
gonna put the pile in there pilot change
Oh
storytime m'dear great
oh no B you can turn off auto does so so
che shed lets in the dear was the ship
sorry it's begging me to pick a ship
okay so who would you like let's let's
do the only other ship we got pull that
on put it on I don't even know how to
okay power now you're speaking now we're
cooking with gas now we're cooking with
gas
oh let's let's see if you let's go let's
go do one thing okay maybe you can take
it off here's another things that there
aren't much control options which is
frustrating part swapping by do there it
is you're right never pause oh okay nice
you keep playing sick good call crime oh
oh is it I popped off the ship no no
that wasn't that wasn't because I was
switching parts it's because I popped
off the ship
is it reversed right now yeah how do I
get a gun on here
or is that a gunner oh you know what
this is pretty loosey-goosey oh thank
you you snap it in alright so in theory
alright yeah okay part just disappears
yep there you go figure that give me
some kind of a forward firing weapon
[Music]
couch co-op Eric's having a blast oh I
couldn't see that from this angle all I
see is Eric I'm getting into combat here
you do it alright you tell me what you
want we only have three weapons bud
so give me you need to go void we can go
this this should be alright I'll just be
over here
[Music]
this is couch co-op I I got my are wing
you look like you might need some void
Rockets am i oh no
give me the void Rockets where would you
like the void rock is all I have is void
Rockets you need to tell me you didn't
get out of it what the hills all right
let's dine swap our pilot no why why
would you do that because I want to oh
we could have switched it on the fly
I was bringing in the arwing and let's
bring in Fox hey old Fox guts and shades
gotta go
you need Fox how about Fox with no
weapons you want weapons what are you
looking at what are you looking why
would I want to what kind of weapons did
you want you know what you don't get to
choose since you're being a real give me
I find ya
there's no pilot bucco you know oh I
thought I thought starfox is in there
also my wings are backward it's a little
worse copilot what are you talking about
my wings
your wings are backwards oh I wanted you
to fight dude
fine no no no here's all the weapons are
no here's another question right in
theory I have put the arwing wings on
backwards but the guns are facing
forward therefore it should still work
it should still work yeah
someone wanted to see the toy oh crap
that's the toy up close dude it's out of
focus I know all right
so even though the wings are backwards
he can still fight this is my version of
the Arwen I actually like it better to
be honest you just saying no III do
okay hey Rob it doesn't seem like that
avoid rocket launchers Oh actually no
you know what I don't want to mess you
up giving you Frost would be the
absolute worst right now just because it
would not actually help you I don't know
if you ever heard me say this is that I
came across too many types are so high
level that they were Frost and when I
use frost on them they became stronger
sick yeah it's kind of cool borrowing
TIE fighter yeah yeah see this is uh
this is what we call oh man was that MTV
show pimp your ride
yeah pimp your ride baby there we have
more of a crab don't worry I'll be uh
cuz I don't give a rat's ass about this
I'll be playing right here with your Rob
so the call knowing this is I look
behind me and I want to pull up and I
nosedive but now why don't you uh hit up
boobie ubiquitous software tell them hey
can I stop using this now nope you're
playing with that the rest of the way
ten more minutes Rob you can do it yeah
but I want some other weapons I can't
get out of can't use any other weapons
whoa oh you can't change the weapon tank
now if I have the toy really you can't
press the L or RZR right now your big
dumb toy toy okay I like the way of the
tiler weapon of the type though does it
do it my solar so your left one is a
like solar weapon can you make it solar
try okay I have to use these really
rewetting that you gave me yeah I need
more toys then alright just fine
go back to your pro controller you jack
and mini well that's good toys that's
what's dumb you need all the toys you
don't have to if you play not dock like
this right
that's why the toys are dumb they want
you to buy every single freaking
well there you go guys Rob's hot take I
still think it's cold do-do-do-do-do
would I be annoyed though that could
switch weapons probably if I'm not
playing so I get to kind of troll him
from over here are you really gonna
fight this level five arc primes Optimus
arc Prime's with your level to do that
look sick actually
oh and it's calling him back up damn
yeah you know what this what what a good
time would be right now right is if you
could call on your boys I think you're
right dude I just don't want to play as
anyone else why would you is cooler I
know we've seen this intro three times
but I don't care it's it's Spock it's
got everything in the intro even has the
good luck in the end that's a good
question can you play co-op right now
without changing too much cuz there's
split screen right is there not read
that earlier I thought I thought there
was I don't even know I'm a I'm an idiot
for not knowing you see oops time to
kick some tail
oh it sounds like something's locked on
yeah it did didn't it
co-opted amiss what is this
yeah oh that's a sight but yes we can
local co-op to players to feature split
screen support oh I could play with this
thing we could do that oh yeah yeah we
come and then I'll probably realize why
Rob hates it let me um let me take do
you want to try to do it yeah but I'll
get out of this I'll get out of the you
can play as the arwing and I'll play as
a the nadir ship or whatever once I
figure out how to was this a slide or
just a pull off I guess cool boss fights
going on here
oh man all right kids be careful with
the the figurines I almost like kind of
pulled fox off of it that boss looks
pretty cool though yeah so Rob would you
have to give me the joy concent I'm
gonna play with you yeah let me show you
just go to the I don't know can you drop
in I'm not sure that somebody did ask
that so I mean we might as well figure
it out
I wonder if I use your weapons though or
no it's just whatever these weapons are
right sorry Eric joins the battle
hey guys are cool all along I could have
been flying this sick ship all right
what do I got here a shoulders I did do
that I'm gonna do any when you're ready
so you're ready to them today oh okay
how do i oh that's me
how do I skip this you don't need to see
this again all right what quit the fight
what oh do we have to start the mission
over because I don't know or you died
maybe while I was a to join beat a skip
update there's a secured
why did skips not secured Eric
now you hold why I'm trying to hold what
what's all this get out of this bee bee
there you are there's your boy there it
is
hey hey Rob I don't know I've never
played this game where here we go
alright booster to you a is booster it's
kinda neat do we lose any fidelity a
little bit it looks like are you
dropping to the planet yes if you want
to look at the icon the yellow one yeah
and then hold our I trigger yeah
oh I gotta approach your partner or oh
you just warp in sick when you're too
far away I'm following you let's just
drop down oh I could just follow you
oops wrong button
there's a big ship in my way all right
let's just let's just shoot these guys
on here I'm on the right Rob's on the
left I think Ross is probably bad for
this but no you're good
it's good for it cross is good for it oh
really recover so if you hold are you go
into tank mode or hover mode
if you look at my screen this is where
you could use that RAM look at the left
guys
the left so here's there's something in
here I want to get so I go so you can't
follow you could I can just teleport
right to rob which is nice whose d-pad I
was so the one the one thing I could see
happening is like I was playing with my
brother my brother when I was younger
you can turn it on so you can't you can
I would prefer it friendly fire
sorry go ahead it's like I could see
myself playing with my brother like 20
years ago and it being like him pushing
pause like switches wiping up I just
pick a weapon yeah but I get to pull
them off Jack just pick a weapon I could
pull mine off you can't do that let's
try to do that all right can we go fight
that thing I want to fight that thing we
do that yeah we were just doing
something on the side here a little blue
we got some grabby ride objective here
all right let's do it
feels better than caught split-screen
I'll listen to your ship it sounds like
a motorcycle that's cool how you can fly
oh I did a barrel roll wait did that
yeah I'm just gonna follow you whoo-hoo
we're at maximum strength Rob
are you ready for it I'll turn it on
later damn it yeah your ship so much
faster oh you're doing a little tricks
now you you have to hold the Blue Angels
were here last week okay are you ready
for it
yeah let's do it do we have to hover
alright alright let's stay with weapons
hot
I got to turn it up here
[Music]
where's his weak spot
there it is where is there it was when
he lifts his leg up damn it damn it jack
exactly the only when he lifts it like
there it is see it
I didn't have an angle on I was trying
to avoid its fire no way Rob will kill
this while I just fly around Oh the
armpit nice got him got a little
critical oh there it is the face no [ __ ]
I missed it you know what I need Rob I
need Boyd Rockets I didn't expect it to
I thought we turned that thing off I
thought we turned it off
I thought we turned off the part changer
- maybe it wasn't work for 2-player me -
oh hello
Hernando yeah yeah you're turning in the
Nova in - oh crap oh you're doing the
Nova my fault no I'm not doing that
that's you all right or maybe it's
someone else
it could be that oh there it is
I space my toes nope okay
giving them the business Rob giving them
everything I got it's business time
everything you've got
all right oh they called in the backup
oh I'm stuck in your thingy that's
alright I'm still hearing the Fox music
though it's not here I got it I got a
regen Rob I'm sorry you so you have your
shield X the top button his armpits
exposed oh [ __ ] alright we'll be shield
if you like are taking a lot of damaging
a guy that I got double rockets right
now feeling good it's pretty sick hi
mrs. armpit I got well elemental combo
modifier oh don't mind me why we
ooh this chest there yeah I know trying
to open it up FaceTime FaceTime FaceTime
give him everything we got like at the
double rocket condo I mean I think
you're still doing all the work here but
oh okay I thought I was gonna run me
over after him Rob
hey you where do you think you're going
stay on him
get that animal shoot a vortex at me
know if you're shooting him I don't care
have a vortex on ya no no all right
what's on his home his nest oh what's
that
is it the crystal yeah oh he's got
lasers
not today
not would ramen Eric around the case I
got two legs down there's one more are
you flying
yeah I'm just hovering oh it's belly
belly
shoot the midsection trying to shoot the
midsection oh you got the right angle
there what do I get my special Oh alive
oh he's angry he or she it he's angry
he's gonna self-destruct who knows it's
Polynesian con
oh he's growing the crystals back on the
lake oh yeah but he's also guy he's also
got some friends some ice cyclopses oh
man it's not letting you take off is it
because I'm on the ground
alright I just had to do that I was just
I was gang like stunned you're on
Firefox
Oh
have you used your special yet that you
know I didn't get I don't have it yet
I've been waiting to kind of use it well
yeah that does time here hasn't filled
yet I am staring at it though
is it belly time
oh you almost have special though yeah
all right I'm using it now here we go do
it
where is Falco
I feel like my my stuff does like no
damage
yeah
yes get it I'm frozen she's feeling the
cold
Oh Nelly
got it great teamwork nailed it
boom see this thing does work quick I'll
switch to my it was tough oh yeah ripped
rip its I out we doing put me in a
vortex this could be the answer to
stopping the legion once and for all
must have a Nova Corps can you bring it
to me
sure I'll rip open its core then let me
pluck his prime core
got it let's do let's deliver this prime
core back don't worry I'm gonna warp to
you I'll take it yeah so whenever you're
carrying some like this you can't fly
it's too damn heavy hold our
see you later [ __ ]
Oh Rob I have my special oh it's a pass
it's right by where I am
Oh hold on a shot right there
don't start shooting that yes are
shooting that he'll come out come out
here boy and I'll do it
wait worth it they're all is it just
left trigger hold hold
I got it I got al that animal Tommy's x2
get me off this yeah this is shield
all right we're that let me
all right word is a dude to shoot Oh
lordship erotic that's no that's oh I
just still owe you stealth really that's
it Firefox is still the coolest you
think
target destroyed all right let's go back
all right sorry guys I guess it was just
snow
hey man you never know maybe maybe you
need that style for a mission oh you
guys are dicks
take care of them
fell behind me for us
sorry if I'm missing someone here guys
it's bad
trying to showcase some of that sweet
split-screen alright
recover
are you in there sweet so heavy oh the
equinox you coming aboard it swings on
backwards it's just the beginning and
you're at the heart of it besides I
can't let Carl have all the fun
are we good yeah everybody done writing
how your minimap yeah this is like not
like I take the minimap secondary
secondary player all right all right so
there's the arwing starlings battle for
Atlas here's the nadir ship with shade I
think is their name oops
probably guys show that yeah so and we
were playing a split screen with the joy
cons and he was playing on a pro
controller yeah stay tuned and guess
watch calm for the review I'm sure it'll
be either later today or tomorrow thank
you guys all for tuning and gamespot
live we're live Monday to Friday 11:00
a.m. so sub if you haven't or come back
just to hang out and chat with us we
really appreciate it thank you to Jeremy
for dropping a lot of knowledge in the
chat and thanks for some of the folks
that stayed around for the whole chat or
a whole stream it's great and thanks of
course to Rob take flying them ships my
pleasure I think this is so far a fun
game yeah I actually the switch version
for you right yeah that's what's making
it for you those the Fox having Fox on
the switch which is it which isn't
exclusive like yeah I don't know I mean
this is definitely not for everyone I
can tell you that much
like I for one getting it's there's a
little bit of nostalgia playing here but
regardless the shooting and the flying
all feels pretty tight yeah I mean I had
fun just like playing for 10-15 minutes
with you they're just you know working
on that that boss basically it's rkt
right yeah good I like I like felt the
you know kind of like almost like
feedback from it just watching the
Rockets go it's kind of cool and like
and when you did turn off the like pause
thing when it when you're playing it was
I mean I don't know if you'd ever take
your hand off the controller to switch
apart but it seemed a little bit more
which is Oh as far as doing the weapons
everything yeah it sounds pretty cool so
yeah thanks for tuning in
no worries Jeremy I don't think that's
spamming at all you're giving out info
so we appreciate it
and until next time till the next flight
we are out of here
have a good Monday peace out